ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show I'm very happy that Matthew
Perry finally getting
exposed uh as a uh abuser of people of
women and because I don't want to see
him in any more projects I'm done the
daily mail ran an
expose the other day on Matthew Perry
font your cancelled buddy you're done I
don't want to see Matthew Perry in
anything and they finally had the guts
to run an expose on Matthew
Perry they were like hey you've gotten
away with it for too long he was very
cruel Matthew Perry assaulted women
including his ex
fiance friends actor hurled a table at
Molly herwitz after she confronted him
about cheating and threw a his livein
sober companion against the wall well
well [__] that [__] I don't want to see
him in
anything that's I'm telling you I I will
not if I see Matthew Perry in anything
Netflix HBO Apple
Amazon after this article came out which
is dated January 10th
2024 after this article about Matthew
Perry I do not want to see him in
anything else
I will not watch it I cannot separate
the art from the artist anymore so I
think he better stay in his
house and it probably is a hot tub and
he should stay there just stay in your
hot tub sir you're not allowed in front
of my eyes
anymore I love this by the way I love
going there's something so great about
going after the dead there's so really
he this guy's a junkie who the last few
years of his life were terrible and he
died and absolutely no one revered this
man everyone when he died was like yeah
he he had a rough go of it the best
thing that was said about this guy was
Lisa Kudo going I might adopt his dog
that was the best that was the closest
anyone got to saying anything nice but I
didn't see really anything nice being
said he was a junkie he had a rough go
of it and he died and then the Daily
Mail had to go and dig they had to go
and dig can you imagine being the writer
of that piece who had to call up
everybody and go hi I'm writing an
article about Matthew Perry you want to
go on record I'm writing an article
about Matthew Perry yeah yeah yeah the
one they just put in the ground I want
to expose
him I happy that the Clinton are on
vacation I'm always happy that people
people that need to get
away I'm always happy when people get
when my friends call me and they go I'm
on vacation I'm happy for them I go
good
good people work so [__] hard if you
have the time get away if you have the
time if you have the money if you can do
it get away get a get away they get out
of
there Bill Clinton went down to
Mexico he went to a luxury resort the
governor of California also another hard
worker what is the deficit 68 billion MH
we're in 68 billion in the hole
stressful uh so the president of the the
ex-president of the United States Bill
Clinton and Gavin Nome went down to
Mexico to hang out
um they went to a cool Resort and this
was like uh you know because the
president had a rough week with the
Epstein docs coming out and you know
Bill Clinton's old now he's been he's
been like a vegan for a while he's not I
don't know how good his heart's doing
he's not out there [__] the way he
used to be he's not on the prowl this
was a man who was on the prowl for the
majority of his life it was what pushed
him forward
he became a governor and the president
because he wanted to [__] and he can't
do it and all this information has just
come out and he's at the end of his life
how old is this guy uh Clinton has got
to be he's old this guy he does not look
great he does not look great Hillary's
up there they're old I remember when
they were like young and he's 77 Clinton
yeah Hillary is
76 George W bush
77 I grew up with these
people I grew up with this
gang President Clinton you
know you know he had some you know he's
T he had he took a couple of L's last
week but he looks he looks
happy there's one one thing about it you
know people that are in the
closet when they're out of the closet
are happier usually people that
are you know are have a secret are a lot
happier when the secret is out there's
kind of a weight that has lifted off
them and they just go yeah it is what it
is you know and I think the Epstein docs
for him were kind of like so what
now it's out now it's out do your worst
I'm 77 years old do your worst so what I
went to a pedophile Island you know and
and I and I ped around with a guy who
trafficked young girls and I probably
had sex with many many of them and maybe
some of them got killed but on the flip
side I reformed welfare I did that
remember the jobs
remember the jobs they were good you
know so it's I mean he he's basically
like it's a mixed bag and Gavin Newsome
right after the ex-president is you know
implicated in all the epy and [__] Gavin
Newsome decides um let's go because
Gavin Newsome likes fun he likes fun
it's a it's a it's a quick private jet
ride down to Mexico he he's him and his
wife uh Jennifer Nome who by the way
testified in the Harvey Weinstein trial
remember that yeah and what and didn't
she describe his
penis right yeah yeah she did so the the
Gavin nome's wife the first lady of
California who who testified in the
Harvey Weinstein trial and described
Harvey Weinstein's penis is now ping
around with Bill Clinton who was on the
human traffickers jet
27 times and is mentioned 50 times in
the
deposition so th this is here's what I
mean by that if you can't read between
the lines there uh new and is why like
they don't they're completely
comfortable with sex offenders and and
people that have committed like
egregious sexual crime they have no Pro
there's no there's no like they're not
like
uncomfortable I guarantee you they're
not
uncomfortable nome's wife is not uncom
she is having a ball they're drinking
they're telling them how to be them the
cleans are telling them here's how to be
us here's how you got to do it today's
day and age I would love to
be a a mortar in pestl of guacamole
sitting at the table listening to this
crime family give the last bit of wisdom
this is all they have left they ju at
this age the only thing they have left
they can't come anymore they they can't
they don't have that much power right
they're they're just bags of dust the
only thing they have left is to talk the
only thing they've got is stories and
they want people to listen to them this
is everybody at that age once you get up
into the octogenarian years when you're
in your 80s you don't have anything left
except to tell people Tales because you
know you're about to bite it and the
only thing you have have left is to tell
those who are coming after
you the things you've learned on your
journey and Bill and Hillary Clinton
this is a kind of a this is a big
vacation historically and people don't
realize this people and because the New
York Post is reporting it and the New
York Post is something that you know
most people don't respect and nor should
they even though I have friends there
and but the New York post and it's kind
of a salacious tabloid story right
they're like look at Gavin Nome hanging
out with the human trafficker you know
and and and and and sure to that end
sure
reported but this is the standard
bearers of the democratic party which is
the
clintons are telling Gavin Nome and his
wife how to
become the new Power couple
because the Obamas can't do the
Republican part's in utter
disarray you meaning that there's
infighting and the Democratic party as
well but both both political parties are
[__] the Republican party you have the
Wall Street types they want like Nikki
haly you want you have like um you know
the maggot people for
Trump you know I don't know I don't know
who's once's Vic but I guess people that
are people on red maybe but this is the
Clinton's telling the news you know and
what a great
dinner because you know there's some
Bill's really just saying
listen I let it get away from me this is
he's you know there's a beach walk with
him and Gavin there's a beach walk with
him and Gavin right because they're kind
of a similar guy Gavin's like a [__] boy
you know what I mean he was married to
that chick who's now dating Trump Jr MH
Kimberly guilfoil Newsome yeah so
Gavin's like kind of a pretty boy he
bill they speak the same language
Hillary does not speak the language
of Harvey
Weinstein's testifier testifying about
the penis woman Hillary doesn't speak
her language CU she's like a real wife
Hillary was never a real wife h is like
a [__] you know Hillary's a is a is a
problem and she wants her own thing and
this [__] you know so when her when her
and Hillary have to talk Hillary's not
really excited by that she probably is
but Bill definitely does a beach walk
with Gavin where he goes hey it got away
from
me and just you know just you know you
got to be careful out there because they
you know it's not like it used to be
this is a different world now can you
imagine just Bill Clinton you know at
the end of it being like hey I mean
listen and you know like he definitely
says to Gavin like he goes they're
trying to say that I was like doing
stuff on Epstein's Island and you
Gavin's got like looks at him strangely
and Clinton's like can you believe that
like they're trying to tie me into that
and Gavin's like I
these Clint like these kinon types
they're trying to tie me in to this uh
eping stuff I mean that's how perverted
these people are it's how sick they are
and Gavin's kind of like like going like
like you Gavin's face kind of
like yeah no it's these people man
they'll just I mean they don't care
about the truth at all Bill's like right
I I mean it's it's insane what they're
doing and they're having a little Beach
Walk and Bill's Bill's a really smart
guy so Bill Bill's not out out there
like people think that Bill's probably
like and then I'll [__] this one and
that one and then we drown one of them
like he's not they're not doing that
he's like setting it up so he's telling
Gavin like they're lying about me
they're gonna lie about you this is what
they do they lie and you have to get one
step ahead of their lies that's where
the fun comes in that's where the fun
comes in cuz Bill's like yeah yeah yeah
you got to get out you got to go one
step ahead of their lives because
they're going to they're going to make
up a bunch of [__] about you they made
up a lot of stuff about me and Hillary
they never stop cuz the cleans are
boomers so they're the victims the
cleans are there only to complain to
Gavin and his wife about how badly
they've been treated by the now by the
way much like Boomers they haven't been
treated barely they should have both for
what they've done been hung but nobody's
done that to them they're not in jail
any other people that you know did the
things they did would probably be in
jail they've actually been treated
pretty [__] well like most Boomers
but de Clinton are at the very heart and
soul of them AG grieved uh Boomers who
are telling Gavin Nome and his
wife who described Harvey Weinstein's
egg penis I can't stop saying that
because it's funny or I forget it's not
an egg but he it's got Gang Green his
Gang Green penis and and they're just
complaining
the whole trip is there's some laughing
and there's some you know keeping it
light but the whole trip is just the
Clinton's complaining about how you know
how bad and Hillary's like and they went
at me they never stopped from the minute
I raised my head I became the symbol of
everything that they hated about women
and about femin and you know Gavin and
the wife are sitting there and there
having some tequ
and drinking a Don Julio Blanco and
they're like yeah yeah know it's we saw
it you guys were just I mean they NE I
mean they never I mean short Bill's not
perfect but they never
stopped it's annoying it's Anno you know
they're just the the news are sitting
every day but the news are sucking it
all up because the news are like how do
we how do we convince the uh country
that we're not going to you know [__]
everybody over how do we do that how do
we do that and Newsome's not Clinton
like Clinton's really good or he was
really
good but it's got I would just love to
be sitting there and listening it's 90%
the Clinton's complaining 90% but then
there's going to be 10% like here's what
you got to do to get the things you want
and that would be the interesting stuff
yeah here's the people to talk to these
are the guys that have to like you
here's the way it
works you know you need a bigger War
chest than you used to you know why do
we really think Hillary lost
D but a lot of it is U uh just
complaining it's probably very boring
it's actually not people think it's like
sexy and lurid and cool and wow it's
whoa what what's it like what it really
is is just an old Boomer couple
complaining because they're just Boomers
by the way I mean May maybe he [__] a
bunch of teenagers he probably did I
would bet money that he did and maybe
she's like a lesbian or something I
don't know she doesn't seem to love [__]
but I don't know so maybe they lived lot
but how many Boomers did that tons tons
they're just Boomers they just got
involved in a bunch of shady deals
they're they don't care about anyone but
themselves their entire lives were about
advancement and now they've got nothing
left except to bring and Gavin and his
wife are idiots they're dumb people
they're stupid people Gavin's an idiot
and his wife's an idiot and a
[__] seemingly I don't know and I mean
I hope none nobody finds any of this
disparaging if anyone plays this for
people play things sometimes for people
but Gavin's a idiot and his and his wife
is kind of an idiot [__] uh from what I
gather I don't know them but this is
what I gather and people that I know who
know them this is the what they believe
gather is a like a silver tonged smooth
talking person but he has no depth he's
as deep as a puddle there's nothing
there he's uh
incapable of uh summoning and he's
really just like and the way that he's
been able to run California is because
people here are stupider than they are
in other places so because he is
good-looking and presentable because the
people here are dumb they are unable to
like they can't under like they look at
him and they go he he's probably telling
some kind of truth but he's an
idiot so and Clinton's they know that
they're looking at them and they're
going like like Hillary says in the
hotel room she's an idiot [__] she goes
she's a dumb
[__] I mean she's she's dumb and Bill
goes yeah I don't know if he I don't
know if they have it I don't know and
and Hillary's like yeah I just don't
think they have it and Bill goes he's
got potential bill goes he's got because
Bill likes him because Bill likes him
for the same reason that that bill likes
anybody he sees parts of himself in
Gavin he's a Gavin's a striver he's a
liar he's probably [__] a lot like Bill
Bill likes that bill goes I think he's
got potential and then Hillary's like
yeah but you know I worry about
her what would be great is if the
clintons decided to kill them like if
they just killed
them and then just that was it like if
the Clinton just decided to
poison Gavin new and for what I I don't
know uh even why they would do I
recorded a patreon episode years ago was
called Bill and Hills last kill about
how there will be a time when they just
have one more kill that's it there's
like one more guy to get rid of but they
there's no reason to kill these people
here but it would be fun there'd be
something beautiful on Shakespearean
about Nome and the wife going to get the
secrets from the clintons and the
secrets going and here's the biggest
secret and then Gavin and his wife dead
in the guacamole poisoned that would be
great like the Clinton laid it out told
them how they did everything told them
everybody they made disappear everything
they just I mean they just unburdened
themselves they're about to die they
completely unburdened themselves in this
legendary dinner and they're drinking
[__] tequila and they're just I mean
SP spilling their guts spilling it cuz
they need to and then they just poison
Nome and his wife and kill them there
and go we we're glad we got that all uh
off our chest but it's it's not going to
be that that would be beautiful and
Shakespearean and great but it's not
that it's just it's Clinton complaining
it's he's talking about the benefits of
veganism like it's it's just it's it's
not what you think it is it just kind of
sucks like I was reading this AR article
about skull and bones and skull and
bones sucks now Skull and Bones used to
be like you know the leaders of America
it's still that but everyone sucks
because the the they're they're doing
like diversity equity and inclusion in
the Illuminati in Skull and Bones which
is used to be just let's get a bunch of
people that show that they can carry
on uh the tradition of being a sociopath
that's what scullin bones is about mhm
it's like finding rich people that have
a skill set that makes them look like
maybe maybe hey maybe they could be
sociopaths and it's it's in at Yale
University the CIA started it was taken
right out of skull and bones okay so
many uh bonesmen have risen to positions
of prominence and power the you know
presidents CEOs we get it a lot of white
guys a lot of white guys they would jerk
off in the coffins it was very like Nazi
I think George W bush stole jono's skull
and it was in the Tomb and there's all
this secret [__] in the Tomb and now
it's like annoy they're annoying now now
it's like they're annoying they
literally in the Skull and Bones tomb
like took down all the pictures of the
old white guys because it's it was not
diverse can you imagine getting into
skull and Bones the most elite sanctum
and then going God this God does this
suck I mean it is like and by the way
they don't take whites anymore they're
not taking a lot of white people they
take like only a few whites they take a
lot of minorities who are the first
person in their family to go to
college this is what skull and bones is
doing the first generate like it's like
it's like a it's
insane like someone that gets tapped the
way Skull and Bones works is when you're
a junior at Yale or something you get
tapped or maybe maybe it's seniors
seniors get tapped into it what I don't
know I'm not in it
okay and and that's not where the real
power is anymore the the power is not in
that it's not these people at Yale
anymore and we'll go into who it is but
it's they have some of it but they're
losing it all the time they're losing
using it all the time but you get tapped
into this and then you got to go through
this
initiation and then you're in this thing
and it's all it's all like
people that are annoying
now except they want all the benefits of
that power structure they want to get
jobs they want to make lots and lots of
money but they they want to
like go like like like like [__] these
colonizers but they're in the thing
they're like in the thing they just want
to make they're like we're GNA make this
Elite Society of uh rich people good
we're g to make it good it's it's it's
this is how
stupid our
political reties are at the moment this
is how how these kids brains have been
melted they're in this inner sanctum
they call it a tomb it's like a the
tombs right and they're and they're
there and they're going we want to be
elite rich people that cover each
other's backs but we we we want to like
also we want to make it good we want to
do it for the right reasons and it's
like the most
psychotic thing by the way you read
about all these other societies where
they all go we're going to give all the
money back to New Haven they don't do
any of that they just hang out they're
college kids they're all I don't care
how smart you think you are you're an
idiot when you're 18 you're an idiot
you're all idiots you're all [__]
stupid I don't give a [__] how smart you
think you are you're you don't you know
nothing of anything draftking sports
book an official sports betting partner
of the NFL playoffs is bringing you an
offer that'll help make the playoffs
electrifying new customers can bet five
bucks on any game and get 200 instantly
in bonus bets I mean that's
great download the draftking Sportsbook
app now and use code Tim Dylan new
customers can bet us five bucks to get
200 instantly in bonus bets only on
draftking sports book with code Tim
Dylan the crown is
yours gambling problem call 1800 GBL or
visit
ww. 1800 gambler. net in New York call
8778 Hope New York or text Hope New York
467 369 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling call 888
78977 77 or visit ccpg
dorg please play responsibly on behalf
of booill Casino and Resort in Kansas 21
plus age varies by jurisdiction void in
Ontario bonus bets
expire 168 hours after issuance C dk.com
for eligibility and deposit restrictions
terms and responsible gaming resources
and I know people are out there going
like yeah yeah yeah but they got into
Yale Tim and you dropped out a Nas
Community College okay yeah but I'm in
Santa Barbara a lot aren't I [__] so
what
happens to these people are at the peak
of their idealism and and and and
they're going into these old
uh institutions that are yes of course
they're racist and all the bists of it's
this [__] skull and bone society and
all these people go in there and they
all have this idea that they're going to
be different they're going to change it
they're going to use it for good I'm
using skull and bones for God but they
all just become rich Pricks that's all
it is that's all skull and bones is you
just become rich prick I don't care that
you're you're a
biracial
bisexual nonbi it doesn't matter you'll
be all of those things in addition to
being a rich
prick who's trying to get ahead based on
the fact that you know other Rich Pricks
is what it is and I'm not saying I'm not
even hating on that there's just such an
insane instead of just scrapping it just
scrap it just get rid of it if you
really don't like it don't be in it say
no when they tap you go no not for me
I'm going to do it on my own but none of
these scumbags want to do it on their
own you know like people like like me or
Trish pis have
done but none of these
scumbags want to do what on their own
they all want the [__] benefits of
being in this little
cabal but they just want the cabal to be
arranged around the things that they
think are more uh altruistic of better
things
it's so [__]
stupid message me if you're in Skull and
Bones by the way it's hilarious it's
it's not Elite anymore no one cares you
[__] losers no one cares you broke
hoes nobody's skull no [__] Skull and
Bones PE very few of them can afford
[__] I talk to the biggest realtors in
the country none of you can buy [__] you
you get nothing some of them a few of
them but a lot of them they have nothing
now they have nothing I'd rather join a
Chinese secret society my godson will
join a Chinese secret society okay he
will join [__] scroll and wanton or
whatever they have he will not join this
[__] can you imag you're in the Skull
and Bones tomb and these
idiots start talking about [__] you
know
the fact that uh they they're they're
they're mad that Angela Basset didn't
win the [__] I mean Jesus Christ is
anything can't people just be evil
anymore can't you just be eil why do we
have to get adjusted to a new kind of
evil all the time can't we just know
what evil is and regard it when we see
it and know how to avoid it or mitigate
its effects what is evil why is it so
godamn good at morphing
all the time all these sociopathic
personality types constantly are are
rebranding themselves so it's very hard
to know what [__] evil
is it's amazing it's like you think you
would just get used to one type of
[__] evil now it's like you know it
you know it keeps morphing and changing
the Skull and Bones Equity let's let's
some of this article did make me laugh
this is written by somebody named Rose
horor witch I feel like that's a fake
name hor witch one evening in 2019 in a
windowless building known as the Tomb in
the center of the Y's campus the members
of Skull and Bones snapped there they
were having by the way how hilarious is
that the members of Skull and Bones
snapped isn't this supposed to be a
thing of like cool serpent-like people
that are good Under Pressure like when
they pull IR ran Contra or something
they
snapped there they were having been
granted membership to the most elite
secret society at one of the most elite
universities in the World part of a rare
group that for Generations included
individuals from the most powerful
Vander uh families on the planet
Vanderbilts Rockefellers da d da da
three bonesman would go on to become the
president we know we know we
know but there in the Tomb surrounded by
oil portraits of former bonesman all
white all chosen by the society's alumni
board the current members felt overcome
not by the achievements of those who had
come before them or by the possibilities
that lay ahead but instead by the
organization's long history history of
exclusion so there by the way which is
still going on the whole point of skull
and B and by the way these idiots go to
Yale is there a refund department the
whole point of skull and
bones is
exclusion that's the entire point it's
to exclude
people they just want them they don't
like the way they the way that they excl
illusion was set
up but that's the whole
point so the students did what they felt
had to be done they pulled the portraits
down and replaced them with homemade
signs criticizing the secret society's
record of keeping people of color out of
its ranks can you picture this you get
into the skull and bone Society you're
in the Tomb you're finally there you're
finally in the inner sanctum of power
and and you're sitting there and
everybody goes hey can you give us a
hand and you go what are we going to do
we we we got Coke or something they go
no no no no we're gonna we're GNA take
down the pictures of William F Buckley
and then we're going to put up posters
about how mad we are that uh he was
white what I thought we were G to do
like a party with scrolling key no we
got to do this they pulled the portraits
down and replac them with homemade signs
portraits is a relatively
straightforward and easy ask one member
who participated in the redecoration
told me the way a space looks can have a
large impact on a person's psyche can
you imagine these are the people they're
now tapping give this country to China
give it to China give it to China give
it to China give it to China can you
imagine a member of just Skull and Bones
being like well actually
the physical environment has a very big
impact on someone's psyche the way a
place looks give it to China
now oh my
God people going to accuse me of being
like some type of racist this is not
what I'm I don't care whose Skull and
Bones has in it I don't give a [__] if
they have all blacks all whites all
hispan the whole point of a secret
society is Skull duggery it's [__]
it's exclusion and any way you cut it
dummies the real rebellious move would
be to get rid of it but none of you
[__] want to do that because you want
the benefits of being in this thing but
you want to just be annoying [__] you
cannot have it both ways you cannot
benefit from this network of [__]
Illuminati Freaks and then take their
photos down dummy you should all be
forced to go to Barry Weiss's University
of Austin that's where you should go you
go right to Barry whites
now that's what happens if you're really
about it skull and bone if skull and
bones is really about it [__] the Yale
Rolodex [__] all the [__] uh alumni
and the [__] uh endowments and all
the bull you go right to Barry Weiss's
University of Austin that's where you go
and you do it on your own sick of these
freaks so many people are getting in car
accidents and so many people are getting
ripped off you know why because they're
not going to Morgan and Morgan it's
America's largest personal injury Law
Firm 35% of all fatal accidents occur
between 600 p.m. and midnight people
aged 25 to 34 have highest amount of
drivers involved in car crashes people
aged 15 to 24 had the highest rate of
emergency room visits due to car
accidents of all age groups
okay Morgan Morgan is America's largest
injury Law Firm you got to use them with
over $15 billion dollar recovered for
over 300,000 clients Morgan and Morgan
has a proven track record of fighting to
get you full and fair compensation they
only make money if you win submitting an
injury claim is so easy life is hard but
the injury claim that you submit is easy
the accident is the tough part getting
in the accident
but the the suing if you have to do it
is easy because you have to hold people
accountable if you're ever injured you
could check out Morgan and Morgan their
fee is free unless they win for more
information go to forthepeople.com or
dial pound law pound 529 from your cell
phone that's forthepeople.com Tim or
pound law pound 529 from yourself this
is a paid advertisement everybody ask me
that com St in my house they go we love
these mattresses what are they and I go
they're Helix it's
true I mean Helix is like amazing
everybody's like these are the best
mattresses I've ever like experienced in
my life I'm telling you Helix is great
all you do is you take a quiz to find
out what kind of sleeper you are what
things are important to you in a
mattress and your personalized mattress
is shipped straight to your door free of
charge Helix knows there's no better way
to test set a new mattress in by
sleeping on it in your own home that's
why they offer 100 night trial and 10 to
15E warranty to try out your new Helix
mattress everybody is unique and
everyone sleeps differently that's why
Helix has several different mattress
models to choose from each designed for
specific sleep positions and feet
preferences models with memory foam
layers to provide optimal pressure
relief if you sleep on your side models
with more responsive foam to cradle your
body for essential support in stomach
and back sleeping positions no matter
what you are or how you sleep Helix
they're with you you just got to fill
out the quiz it takes a second it's a
split
second you do the quiz it's the easiest
quiz in the world you just you know they
ask you a few questions about your
genealogy your lineage you know like
where your family comes from what
countries they come from and they try to
put a composite together you know
it's
kidding and their mattresses are
fiberglass free they do not contain
fiberglass which can be harmful to your
health no fiberglass in the
mattress all these other brands they got
fiberglass there no none of that now
stop
it Helix is offering 20% off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners go to helixsleep.com
timd use code Helix partner2 that's
helix sleep.com / timd and use code
Helix partner2 this is their best offer
yet and it won't last long with Helix
better sleep starts now one of our
favorite themes on the show now is
reading articles from The Wall Street
Journal I don't know what's going on
there and I I don't know anyone
there the Wall Street Journal seems to
be the head
publication uh it's appointed
itself the publication that is trying uh
the hard is to prepare you for the
nightmares of which they are convinced
you are going to
experience the Wall Street Journal has a
new article called here's what it's like
to retire on almost nothing but Social
Security listen again to the words
because they're my favorite there is a
woman here in a subdivision maybe
Gilbert goons and she's in a wheelchair
and she's got a dog and she's
smiling here's the Wall Street Journal
headline again it's great here's what
what it's like to retire on almost
nothing but Social Security four
retirees with limited incomes open up
about how they make it
work many Americans reach retirement
with almost no savings no 401K few
Investments and almost no income aside
from a monthly social security
check social security was never fully
intended to support retirees said an an
Anquan assistant director of savings
research at Boston colleges Center for
Retirement Research the average monthly
social security check is about 1,900
that doesn't go as far as it once did
said Sandy markwood CEO of us
aging adding that inflation and Rising
rents have led more older adults to seek
help from her nonprofits Elder Care
locator tool and other organizations
that provide help to seniors so here's
what and I haven't read the article yet
but here's what I'm betting it is they
are not going to present this as a
desperate situation for these seniors
they're going to present this as like a
fun challenge it's like a fun late in
life challenge to figure out how you're
going to eat Eric Miller never wanted to
leave the kitchen the professional chef
thrived on the intensity of restaurant
life often working 12-hour days six to
seven days a week a heart condition
landed him in the hospital about 7even
years ago after that he had no choice
but to hang up his knives now 70 Miller
said he was unprepared for sudden
retirement financially or otherwise in
part because he had never planned to
stop
working at the height of his career he
earned about $2,000 a week now his
monthly social security check brings it
about 1400 he rents the basement of his
sister's home for about $500 a month
including electricity his other main
expenses include food gas and insurance
his six heart medications are largely
covered by Social
Services about seven years ago he moved
to Arizona to care for his aging mother
as her dementia and Alzheimer's worsened
when she had a stroke he took a nearly
two-year career break to help care for
her full-time until she died he
eventually moved back to Virginia where
he worked for a few more
years though money is tighter than he
would like Miller is proudly debt-free
so now here's where it turns here's
where now now remember remember he's
cared for his aging mother he's living
in a basement he's living in a basement
of his sister's house okay for 500 a
month but here's where the Wall Street
Turtle here we go put on a happy
face the money is tighter than he would
like Miller and by the way people say
like they're like are you making up
these articles these are you read them
you go and read them we'll post them
remember do you think I could make that
up where they're like you don't need a
bathroom mhm what is this 1998 dining
room kitchen no the new houses are a
single hallway with little cages on
either
side he paid off though money is tighter
than he would like Miller is proudly
debt-free he paid off more than 12,000
in credit card debt this summer with the
help of nonprofit Financial counseling
agency Green Path Financial
Wellness he also got reliefed from his
roughly ,000 in medical
bills uh for his four heart procedures
thanks to the hospital's charity I feel
a lot less
stressed in retirement he embraced
budgeting for the first time that's see
that what that basically says is he was
a
scumbag that little line is important in
retirement he embraced budging for the
first time so basically they're saying
this guy's a scumbag now they told you a
few paragraphs earlier that he literally
stopped his life to care for his aging
mother but now they're saying but he was
a scumbag he didn't budget anything he
didn't know where his money was he was a
scumbag you know you know he was just
taking care of his elderly mother with
dementia but he wasn't watching the
money I work on my budget religiously he
said sounds
fun he regularly tracks his spending in
a spreadsheet
W some month he has about $150 left over
which usually buys him more food than he
particularly likes such as chicken and
vegetables I mean the lives they are
preparing you for I'm I'm
folks listen to me right
now the former High School athlete
enjoys watching football and basketball
on television his dog died last year but
he's considering getting a new one I'll
probably go to the pound he said the
lives they are preparing you
for are are un
believable they are
unreal they are basically writing these
articles to go things are going to be
okay there'll be some Financial uh help
perhaps delivered through charity or
certain organizations and you might get
that you might not but you better budget
you better budget because you're Canon
have about $150 left at the end of the
month and you can have some chicken you
can get some extra chicken you want some
extra
chicken and maybe maybe you can get a
dog and feed him some of the
chicken Kathy Road has been an advocate
for people with disabilities her entire
adult life retired social worker still
helps friends with age related Mobility
problems seniors are generally
embarrassed by disability it takes
confidence to say I have this disability
and it's within my right to seek
accommodations Afflicted with polio is
an infant rot knows the challenges and
expenses of life with a disability today
she lives on ,40 social security check
thousand thousand
as a child she used leg braces and
Canadian canes to get around and
recounts being bullied in school the
obstacle she encountered Inspire her to
work for years as a at a nonprofit in
Berkeley
California she used the motorized
wheelchair da 1993 she lacked a salamina
to work full-time and claim Social
Security disability insurance at around
age 66 those benefits stopped and she
began getting retirement benefit she
moved to Tucson Arizona where she's
attended College a folk singer and a
guitarist she joined a group that uh had
started the Tucson Folk Festival years
before well that's
nice the whole point of this is that
it's actually good she's good we're all
happy she gets a thousand a month and
she's happy and if if she maybe she
could eat her
guitar she bought a home with a 60,000
her uncle left her and has no debt she
shares the home with Archie her 90 PB
rescue
dog she supplements to 200 she spends on
food each month with a $157 benefit from
her Medicare which she uses to pay for
over-the-counter medication and
groceries hiring attendants to help with
house cleaning wheelchair maintenance
and food prep costs cost her about 300 a
month rote said the recent deaths of her
mother and five friends have convinced
her to make the effort to see people so
she hosts occasional parties on her Pat
see it's
fine she's having parties on the patio
we sing songs and eat some food and talk
about what really matters to each of us
yeah Joyce mckin she's
77 she doesn't have any money either
let's see how Joyce mckin is doing okay
it's really really tough you don't know
what the future is going to bring it was
an extremely difficult time she's lonely
anxious with
money uh since okay now she feels a bit
more secure though far from flush she
had found ways to to stretch her $1,800
social security check since downsizing
she pays about 343 a month for a storage
unit her rent Rose recently to $584 a
month she spend $68 a month for basic
cable and 77 for her cell phone an
insurance policy cost her $269 a month
about 150 to 200 each month goes to food
and 100 for laundry she takes subsidized
senior transportation for for a dollar a
ride to get to most places
mckin is active in the social scene at
the senior center where she spends most
of her
weekday arriving at the alagan brand to
the Philadelphia senior center around
9:00 a.m. and catching up with friends
over free coffee and a dollar corn
muffin a dollar corn muffin they bang
her a dollar to have a corn muffin at
the senior
center many of the people here are like
an extended family they make better food
for me than I make for
myself this is a great one Barbara
Talisman is nomadic lifestyle satisfies
both her wander lust and retirement
budget with limited savings the former
fundraiser for nonprofits had planned to
work until at least age 65 but two years
ago with her birthday uh approaching she
chose to call it quits sell her
belongings and claim Social Security
life is short I was done I wasn't going
to wait another three years good for
her
okay now she puts some money in
savings okay now she goes Globe trading
she booked four week long backtack
cruises to Mexico in the fall of 2021
when prices were low D due to lingering
covid concerns so that's nice so during
a global pandemic this woman was forced
to take back-to-back cruises it's not
bad
um lovely travel travel yeah travel
travel
travel things are
fine she doesn't have a lot of money but
she's traveling she's on a cruise she I
think you know she has a
small wait hold on let's go up there for
a second where does she live her food
average is 300 a month in car insurance
that recently she's been seven months in
California spending about 500 a month on
hotels between house sitting
cicks so she's a house sitter she
doesn't really have a permanent place to
live but it's fun it's actually fun
because she gets to house sit in other
people's
homes that's nice it's a fun way to do
it she house and you know it's great
because you know listen we're not going
to nobody's trying to help any of these
people nobody's trying to help any of
these people nobody's trying to help any
of these certainly the people skull and
bones are not they're not trying to help
any of these people so you just got to
put a nice put a good spin out on what
they're doing if they're house sitting
or they have to live on a cruise or you
know they just you know a lot of these
by the way are just like and she has a
dog that's a lot of a lot of them are
like she may have no money she may be
stretched to the Limit where she has a
$100 a month left but she's got a dog
and isn't that good she went to the
pound to got a dog and the other guy can
occasionally eat more chicken so the
Wall Street Journal is like things are
good things are fine things are
absolutely fine people are eating
chicken they got dogs they're house
sitting in other people's houses they're
dying in hotels and on cruises that's
fine it's fine what are you going to do
what are you going to do help them what
are you going to put together some type
of uh you know program so that these
people ah come on it's fun it's a fun
challenge it's fun to house sit when
you're in your 70s it's nice it's fun to
bounce
around house
sitting that's great you should be how
lucky to be so Bohemian in your old age
how lucky to be so Bohemian in your old
day or live with your sister for 500 and
finally learn a budget you
scumbag thank God you learn get that
spreadsheet out you
scumbag you were just trying to help
your mother with dementia well you
should have had that spreadsheet then
where was the spreadsheet then you
wouldn't be here you piece of [__] I
tried to get tickets to the era tore
with Taylor Swift and I couldn't and my
entire family wanted to go with me and I
promised him that I would get tickets
and literally it was sold out couldn't
get the tickets and do you know what my
entire family did and I don't even want
to say this because it's not
right my uncle when I told him that I
cannot get you and your children tickets
to the Eros store my uncle put all of
his his wife and his
children in a
car and he drove them into a lake and
they all
died and they were listening to Taylor
Swift because he said this is as close
as we're gonna
get this is as close as we're gonna get
and I don't want you to have that I
don't want you to have that story to
tell in your
life so I would like you to use the game
time
app it's the best you can get tickets to
anything comedy music Sports last minute
tickets Flash Deals Zone deals easy to
find to buy tickets for every kind of
event your area views from all seats in
the venue lowest price guarantee event
cancellation protection job loss
protection Etc game time has deals on
tickets right after start of the event
and even a after an hour after it starts
even it's a place to find last minute
seats find exclusive Flash Deals and
sponsor deals on tickets for football
basketball baseball concerts comedy
theater and more with Zone deals you
pick the section and Game Time picks the
seats for Big Time
Savings the game here is it's not only
easy to do but it saves you money the
game time guarantee means you'll always
get the best price if you find tickets
in the same section and row for Less
game time will credit you 110% of the
difference and your family will not be
in a car in a Lake
drowning screaming at me on the phone
screaming at me going oh you couldn't do
it wait till you see what I'm gonna do
now and in the background they like Dad
no no
stop and and he's blasting it's a love
story like a sick person it's a love
story and he swam away and got
out and me and him are fine
now download the game time app create an
account use code Tim for 20% off your
first purchase terms apply again create
an account redeem code tiim for 20% off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest prices guaranteed we're
ending with a sad story speeding driver
strikes and kills girl six while she
played outside her house and mockingly
called her a [__] to Cops who arrive
to investigate that's not great a North
Carolina man struck and killed a
six-year-old while speeding past her
house and C her a [__] two cops who
arrived on the scene Andrew Everett was
charged with involuntary manslaughter
reckless driving and in speeding for the
December 29th crash it killed uh
six-year-old Joselyn Perez Hernandez
Hernandez's family said she was playing
near the sidewalk in front of her home
and carry just before noon and the
vehicle struck her I think the girl had
Down syndrome according to the warrant
Everett said quote I'm not sure why this
investigation is taking more than five
minutes it wasn't my fault no one was
watching her and she just jumped out in
front of me that
[__] it is unclear if the little girl
was disabled well it looks a bit you
know it feels a
bit I mean yeah that guy yeah yeah that
guy is not going to deal with this uh in
a mature
Way Everett claimed the child jumped out
in front of him but police noticed a
lack of skid marks on the road suggest
he did not try to break oh my
God so maybe he wasn't paying attention
maybe he's just a
psycho this girl died that's a terrible
story terrible MH all
around
there's something amazing about someone
who's just after something like that
completely
remorseless
yeah like someone who's like angry and
like put upon going what is so what why
is this even
happening this should take five
minutes so what I mean just the
remorseless the lack of remorse is
always a fascinating element to me of
that certain people's makeup that they
can do something even by accident that
causes a death and they just go yeah
well I didn't mean to they go yeah but
you don't think about
it you
know I don't know there's a lot there's
a lot of people that just don't they
don't seem to have a lot of
remorse not all of them obviously
there's people out there that are very
deeply in touch with their humanity and
you know but there's there are people
out
there that maybe shoot uh
cinematographer instead of a movie and
aren't they don't seem broken up about
it but maybe that's just the way you
need to move
on that's the other
thing maybe you just need to move
on like
maybe you can't dwell on
on someone you shot several minutes
ago or someone you hit with a
car you know a half hour ago maybe you H
you know we have to move on as
people it doesn't no good to dwell on
the
past so are these people remorseless or
are they forward
thinking that's a that's true because
there are a lot of people our buddy her
our buddy Caitlyn had an accident in
Malibu did it sideline her I don't know
I I think be and that but by the way
that's the attitude that makes a
champion that's really the attitude that
makes a
champion she's like I don't think she
meant to do it I think circumstances
being what they were unfortunately she
ended somebody's life in her
vehicle
but you
know the term onward and upward exists
for a
reason it's not I mean I didn't just
invent it it's actually a thing that
people say onward and upward I
auditioned for a movie recently I didn't
get it and yet still my manager said
onward and
upward we actually just went next
but I wish he said onward and upward he
just went next which is maybe what
Caitlyn said next maybe she was like
next or maybe this guy was just next or
our buddy Alec Baldin maybe was like
next I don't know I don't know I am not
a
genius we know Tim but I do have some
insight into The Human Condition and
people often have to move
on they must move on
and the and and and and that that really
is an important part of life and I think
that you know this man who this is a
horrible thing that this girl died it
was it was not nice that he called her a
[__] after hitting her with his
car but that is what he believed caused
the
accident in fairness to him and he's
probably not an eloquent person I look
at him and I go he's maybe not an yeah
that is not an eloquent man that is not
a man who went to Yale so that is not a
man who he's probably um in articulate
he doesn't exactly
know how to express his emotions in a in
a in a way that wouldn't
offend like saying like if I were him I
would have said this is a great tragedy
I'm so sorry she just jumped out of
nowhere nobody was watching her it
seemed like something maybe was wrong
with
her I wouldn't have said why is this
taking more than five minutes that
[__] jumped out I wouldn't have said
it those were his words not mine those
were his words not
mine
um but this is a
man who understands the need to put the
past behind
him you know there's many and by the way
how different is he than the Bill
Clinton not too different
Bill Clinton's like let's say let's
leave it there let's leave the past
there onward and upward let's move
on you think Bill Clinton wants a real
examination of the p no America's best
days are ahead of
her it's time to move
on that's why he brought the new Sims to
Mexico to talk about the future that's
what they were discussing not the
past talking about the future and what
it will bring and all the good things
that are going to come
you know and that's what this guy was
doing in his own way with his little
shitty car on a side street driving a
little fast killing this poor girl
nothing good about any of that but he
was just doing what Bill Clinton was
doing Life's a weird random place this
guy's going let's move on Clinton's in a
a luxury resort in Mexico essentially
saying the same thing let's move
on how many lives did Clinton run more
than that guy probably right
yeah so it's just interesting random odd
but that's what that's what we're doing
here can't make sense of
it but if you want to see a comedy show
you should go to Tim Dillan comedy.com
and get tickets to come see me it'll
make the night fun don't kill anyone on
the way home but if you
do that shouldn't you know inhibit you
from going on and doing the things you
normally do
Bethlehem Pennsylvania Washington DC
Northfield Ohio San Antonio Texas Dallas
Atlanta St Louis Indianapolis Boston
Boston Boston another Boston probably
we're gon to add a force show at the
Wilbert Connecticut Foxwoods Chicago uh
Fort Lauderdale India
Phoenix couple more casinos being
announced
too we'll be keeping an eye on all the
stories for you some Gilbert goons
updates on the patreon interesting stuff
happening God I wish I was into [__]
Mexico with the Gavin Newsome and the
clintons I really wish I was there but
at the end of the day it's like God it
looks so
fun Gavin Newsome with his cut off
Converses and his wife God it looks so
fun oh poor
Bill oh here's the beachwalk it's
unclear if former presidential candidate
and exse Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton was also with the resort oh they
left her home oh how sad Hillary's not
much for
parties you know that's what Bill said B
Hillary's like I don't want to see
them because they're gonna talk about
how Gavin can become president that's
gonna depress her she's gonna be
depressed so Bill's taking that walk on
the
beach Bill's giving him the advice he's
the Young
Gun this is like the last time anyone's
gonna ask for Bill Clinton's advice he's
a [__] suspect in a human trafficking
probe
this is the last [__] time
anyone is going to take a beach walk
with Bill Clinton and go hey buddy how
do I do it this is it this is the last
time Bill Clinton can be like in some
type of Elder Statesman before he's just
complete because this is the tip of the
iceberg what's going to come out about
all this stuff I mean it'll be terrible
his legacy is going to go down in
literal
Flames so this is the last time you can
walk on a beach in Mexico and give this
other scumbag advice about how to
bamboozle everybody into thinking that
this scumbag cares about
them and there's something nice about
that there's something nice about that
in a world that changes every minute
every second when we can hold on to very
very very little there are some nice
things that stay the same and one of
them is that somewhere on this planet a
sociopath will walk down the resort walk
down the beach of a resort and tell
another
sociopath how to be a better
sociopath okay and neither one of them
needed to be in [__] [__] skull
and bones